thanks to the organizer and thanks all
all for staying till the very last talk
of this code for insulin okay so this is
joint work with Nathan Taylor and in
current muscle so I'll talk about the
influences in the Gaussian space so the
project grew out of the following
question so is there a natural
definition of the influences of
functions defined on the Gaussian space
so this is a function of n iid gaussian
random variables and how can you define
the in a natural way the influences of
this function okay and so I will give
you the definition hopefully that will
you will find it attractive and then I
will show that like there are many
fundamental results in the discrete
space and you can also prove the
Gaussian analogs of those results using
this Gaussian influence so for example
this k KL bound the Rousseau's lemma and
the threshold phenomenon for monotone
sets benjamina college from my
sensitivity theorem etc and I will also
indicate how you kind of extend this
notion to more general probability
measure measures so that's the kind of
the outline of the talk okay so so first
few slides will be the review of the
like the fundamental results in the
discus spacer so you have seen this
definition of the influences of boolean
functions probably n times in this
conference I'll state it n plus 1 string
so so you have a function defined on the
hyper cube boolean valued and the hyper
cubed is equipped with the uniform
measure or the product Bernoulli measure
you define the jet influence of the
function by the following probability so
you flip the jet coordinate and you
compare the value with FX and if they
are different you put 1 otherwise you
put 0 and you take the expectation with
respect to
so examples of course they are these are
two kind of the most standard example so
first example is majority where all the
variables behave in the same way and for
every J the influence of this function
or influence of the set is 1 over square
root n and then you have dictator which
depends only on one coordinate and so
all the other coordinates have influence
0 only the coordinate which is depends
in this case it's one have full
influence that is influence equal to one
okay and so this success story of
influence of the boolean functions in
the disk you cube is fairly long and
there are many applications in phase
transitions for collisions extremal
combinatorics hardness of approximation
so such as theory and so on and so on
this list is by no means complete ok so
why this is useful this infamous theory
there are many results so let me just
give you a few first of all this is very
natural so this has the following
isoparametric meaning that if you take a
subset of the hypercube you look at the
sum of the influences this is just the
normalized age boundary of the set so
this is a nice isoparametric
interpretation so the next two things is
the KL lower bound on the influence and
the Russos lemma which I'm going to talk
about next
ok so in general if you have a function
boolean function defined on the
hypercube the Efrain stein bound will
tell you or the Poincare inequality
whatever you call it that the variance
of F is bounded by the sum of the
influences and so this gives that the
maximum influences is bounded by the
variance of F divided by n so in one of
this kind of most fundamental result and
in this discrete harmonic analysis
conchal I and will even proved that
actually you can put a log in here in
the lower bound
so so this is a big thing this was a big
thing time and I will talk about some of
these implications and also this result
also hold for the product Bernoulli
measure how do you define the influence
for the product bundle you measure you
use the same definition I mean instead
of the probability with respect to the
uniform measure you take the probability
in respect to the product on elimination
so this is very standard yeah now let's
talk about the rucious lemma so suppose
if we have a monotone set so it's a
monotone in each ordinate okay and
suppose you measure the state with
respect to with respect to this product
boundary free measure now if P increases
this measure of the set increases and
the Rousseau's slimmest tells you that
the derivative of this measure of the
set with respect to P is exactly equal
to the sum of the influences and I put a
P there to indicate that it's kind of
this influences is taken with respect to
the product measure P so so if you have
a as set which is also transitive that
means that kind of this is kind of
weakly symmetric so so the set is
invariant under the permutation under
the action of any transitive subgroup of
the permutation group okay so all the
influences will be the same and the KKL
theorem tells you that the sum of the
influences will be then at least login
so you have a large derivative and that
will give you a threshold phenomenon
proved a filtered and kalaiy in 19:6
so so whenever you have a monotone
transitive set in the discrete cube and
you want to say talk about the threshold
window which is kind of that you you say
your p is the value where the mayor of
the set is approximately epsilon and Q
is the value when the measure of the set
is approximately 1 minus Epsilon and you
want to bound the difference between Q
and P okay
so as a
of the cake and theorem you get that it
is at most one over login of the order
of so this is a kind of a very general
theorem which holds for a great
generality so for example if you take
the erdos-renyi random graph with width
H probability P and you consider the set
which is monotone graph properties so
what do you mean by Moulton graph
properties so it is the property so if
you throw in more edges this property is
satisfied and what do you mean by graph
properties so if you relive all the
vertices the property it
the event is closed okay so for example
if you have connectedness or like the
Hamiltonian or non planar each of this
isn't is a graph property and for each
of this event of is satisfied it is a
monotone transitive set in the minus 1
comma 1 to the power n choose 2 okay and
we have the threshold phenomenon for
these events and actually Bugan and Col
I prove that in in this case of the when
you talk about the graphs here and you
can improve the bound to 1 over log n
square up to some small order correction
yes so I think it's the if you take the
cliques of size log n I think it is hard
so in general here the idea is the most
symmetry you have in the set the sharp
are the threshold you can get okay so if
you just assume like it is invariant
under the I some of physical to graph so
you have some 1 over log n square so
okay so this is the all I wanted to say
about the discrete spaces now I mean a
natural thing to look at is the
continuous spaces like the Gaussian
space proton Gaussian space and can we
define the influences of course we can
there are actually several existing
definition I will talk about two but
there are many more so one is this V 3kl
paper
it's kind of literature known as the
bkkk l paper and where they they've
introduced these following definitions
of the influence so you take the
probability of the set so f is not
constant on the fiber of the point X
along the J direction so that's the and
probability of that set is your J
influence okay and for so these general
edges the for example the definition of
the influence for the P bottom Bernoulli
measure and in this case they prove that
KK L bound steel votes but in general I
mean if you talk about Gaussian species
this lacks the geometrical meaning in
the sense that you can end of part of
part of the value of F on a set with
arbitrarily small major but and then the
part of F will have completely different
set of influences so this is probably
not so natural in that yes there is
another candidate which is very
reasonable so this is called the
variance influence so actually how many
talk about this influence in this talk
so you you fix the all about the is
coordinates so you look at the function
which is now only a function of the I F
coordinate you take the variance of this
1 dimensional function and then you
integrate out the rest of the
coordinates okay and this is a very
reasonable definition but unfortunately
there is no quick l-type bound hold for
this definition so for example you look
at the N dimensional unit cube with the
uniform measure you just define this
simple function that is the indicator
function of the set that the max is less
than equal to 1 minus 1 over N so the
measure of this set is of the roughly of
the constant order but all the
influences are of order 1 over N so this
K can take bounders and hope so
so let us propose this kind of the
following new definition of the
influence and which is kind of we let's
stick to the gaussians create a space
for the moment though the definition was
for other majors to so what we do so
suppose we have a set in RN so fast I
fix the point X then I look at this set
a X J so which is like so I look at the
section one dimensional section of a
along the fiber of X in the J direction
ok then what I do I take the one
dimensional surface measure with respect
to this underlying measure new ok so I
call it by new class which is also known
as the lower miracles because content of
the set so this is a one dimensional
thing and then I integrate out with
respect to all the coordinates ok so for
example if my if my section of this set
looks like an interval A to B and if
this new has a nice density field then
the surface measure is just fear plus PV
so another way to think about this is
the so you have the indicator function
so you kind of approximate it by a
smooth function and then then take the
gh derivative and take the L 1 norm so
this is kind of the kind of the thing
that is captured here ok so remarks here
is that the this definition of geometric
influence that we introduced it doesn't
depend on the product structure of the
measure you can you can do it for like
arbitrary measure but of course you
don't have like interesting theorems for
food for any general measure so ok so
what is the kind of the geometric
interpretation of this measure so recall
that the in the discrete case the sum of
the influences is connected to the h
boundary yeah so we have something
similar
white so if we have a ISO so we have
some regularity assumption that so the
one dimensional measure has some nice
density let's say so one emission
measure I call it mu and then if we take
a Morton set then sum of the geometric
influences of the monotron set is given
by the alien affinity surface measure of
the set so what do you mean by alien 50
surface measure instead of adding an l2
ball there I add an L infinity ball okay
and I I use the kind of the standard
definition of how to define a surface
measure of a set and then so for the
monotone sets this L infinity surface
measure is equal to the sum of the
influences and actually this kind of L
infinity surface measure is actually has
been studied in the literature and it is
called the boundary under uniform a
large meant so I mean it is I mean
monotonicity is not strictly needed for
this theorem to hold you can also prove
this theorem for convex sets or sets
with not too rough boundary but if you
if you it's not true for the general
sets with a very rough boundary for
example a trivial example is if you take
a set with all the rational coordinates
then you can easily check that the
left-hand side is infinity so it's L
infinity boundaries infinity but the sum
of the geometric influence is zero so
this is kind of the connection to the
isoparametric property of the set okay
now in our paper so this is the main
theorem in our paper so we can prove a
fashion of the KL bound for this
geometric influences for the Gaussian
measure okay so when the underlying
measure is gautsche product gaussian
then we can prove this exactly the same
type of statement as given in the cake
and theorem but instead of log so again
we have square root of login
and actually the proofs works not for
the not only for the coefficient measure
but also for a family of measure which
generalizes the gaussian measure this is
known as both my measure where the
density is given by or proportional to e
to the power minus mod extract to the
power r okay so for row equal to two
corresponds to the gaussian case Rho
equal to 1 corresponds to the two sided
exponential but you have a inter family
of measure and the change is instead of
instead of log n power half we have log
n power 1 minus 1 over Rho so Rho equal
to 2 corresponds to 1/2 in general for
two sided exponential in Rho equal to 1
this doesn't give anything ok and I I'm
not saying more about the proofs
actually proves involve several steps so
the two basic ingredients that we needed
for the proof fast is the KKL bound for
the discrete spaces so we somehow needed
that in our proof and the second thing
is kind of the isoparametric inequality
for this boltzmann measure for the
one-dimensional sex so so this has been
kind of the building blocks that we
needed in our proof and some of the and
role of the hyper contractivity is kind
of in is hidden inside this original
KCAL bound
okay and so the theorem I showed you is
tight for the following sets so you you
consider the same infinite box so you
consider the search like of the form
minus infinity to be n power N and you
choose B and so that the Gaussian or the
Boltzmann measure measure of the set is
some fixed constant T which is less than
half then you will achieve the same
bound as given in the theorem
so in general so it cannot be improved
okay
so this KCAL theorem using I mean can be
proved using various ways so there are
also stronger versions of it so one such
famous strong stronger version is Talib
those variants form so if you have a
function defined on the hypercube
so palette don't give gave a variance
bound on the on the function in terms of
this into norm and the l1 norm of the
discrete derivative of this function so
so this is in the right hand side to
involve this beautiful expression
involving this l2 norm and the l1 norm
of this discrete derivative of F okay so
if you set F to be the indicator
function of your set a such that the say
a has measured ting then you can easily
check that the al above inequality
becomes this okay because because this
is discrete derivative is again a 0 1 or
minus 1 value function and if you come
compute the l2 long square or the l1
norms they are both will be the ordinary
influences of the set okay and this this
bounds gives you the KCAL bound so that
that will give you the login over n
bound so Thamud ins theorem is actually
stronger and in our paper we're also
able to prove a Gaussian analogue of
this kind of palindromes type of bomb so
so now there instead of this log minus
log of the influence we have the minus
log of the Gaussian influence to the
power something which comes from the
kind of the this is the Skakel type
bound
in this theorem okay by the way I wanted
to mention one thing that this bound
actually this this power of login it
comes from this kind of isoparametric
functions so in the isoparametric
functions you have these t minus 20 is
less than half it's almost like T times
minus log T to the power 1 minus 1 over
low and this kind of power gets into
here so in our paper kind of we prove
that if we have a kind of sufficient Liz
sets with sufficiently smooth boundary
they are always existed rotation which
kind of which has the sum of the
infinite square root n times the measure
of the set so you can always increase
the in so if yeah so this is a good
point so the Gaussian in measure is
rotationally invariant but our
definition of the influence does not
incorporate that rotational symmetry
yeah so what do you mean oh okay so you
mean this bkl type of area so this
definition of course the one of this if
you okay so one of these this various
dip in fluence for various influence the
K can type bound doesn't hold actually
so the Gaussian or geometric influences
is bigger than this radians influence
but of course it's smaller than the BK k
n type influence so it because it it
holds with log n over N okay so let us
now leave this framework of this
Gaussian space and talk a bit more about
the kind of the general less abstract
mark of semigroups rating so so
subsequently actually this cordero in a
screen and we shall need to solve our
paper and they realize that many things
can be generalized okay in the mark of
similar setting so that's that's I'm
going to describe to you right now so
the setting here is suppose you have a
reversible Markov semi group which
generated L and less the MU is your
invariant probability measure and you
have this solution affirm and here are
the following three conditions so first
you assume that there are operators
gamma I which you can think of some sort
of derivative operator such that your
additional form can be decomposed into
this in this way okay and so I will give
examples for this and then you assume
that this gamma I is
and weekly commutes with the subgroup PT
and sorry semigroup PT so by that I mean
if you apply the gamma I to the function
PT of F okay so this is point twice less
than equal to some constant times the
constant involves like T so it's
constant is e to the power some copper T
when copper moves to the real number of
PT e applied to gamma of f so this you
suppose you have a decomposition like
that and suppose you also assume that
this this semi group satisfies the Lok
Sabha love inequality so this is kind of
equivalent to to say that it satisfies
some high power contractive inequality
so in this setup you can generalize the
tolerance bound so instead of the
discrete derivative there you just put
the these operators combining of it so
one comment here is that there is a
constant and this constant involves the
locks of a constant row so if you have a
small locks on a post and you will have
a weaker bound here so let's okay so
before I move on to the next slides let
us mention that this N 1 norm of this
gamma of F serves as a national
candidate for the influence of F in the
right direction so of course this either
direction is not clear in an abstract
mark of same group X but it will be
clear in the examples okay so I want to
give you three examples so fast is the
bounnam a big narsimha group that L
cannot mentioned in this case you have
this gamma is just the discrete
derivatives okay
and of course loksabha constant is one
so this is so specializing this in the
in this general theorem by lado and
accordion on your screen so actually
gives the solid transparent bound for
the functions defined on the description
okay second you can take this Gaussian
example so when the invariant measure is
the gaussian measure on RL so in this
case if the natural semigroup you take
is the on strain into the mix EMA group
and here the gamma will be just the
partial derivative of the e4 function
okay and and actually this this kind of
commutative relation is satisfied with
cop I equal to minus one you can easily
check by taking the derivative of those
ten little bit semigroup and we have
lots of constant and so on so so we have
the following following kind of variance
bound for the Gaussian space you can go
beyond the pro like product measure so
this is an example of known product
measure so you can take the let's a
transposition work on the as on the SN
which is the set of all permutation on
in alphabets and in this case mu mu is
the uniform measure on s n so in this
case so in this case the so this gamma I
so there is no N in this in this case I
mean the direction the is not clear but
if you think about it the those gamma
operators are now indexed by the set of
transpositions and they are like the
discrete derivative along along the
direction of the transformation and
actually this this result is already
there in the paper of auto rail and
women into 2009 so I mean the result
this variance bomb
now as you can see that suppose I want
to move from this variance bound to
prove Gaussian kkn okay so I want to put
F which is indicator of a now there is a
problem here because if you take the
derivative is the derivative of
indicator of a and you try to compute
the l2 norm it is not clear what is the
meaning of that thing so I mean the l1
norm is your Gaussian influence but l2
norm the meaning is not clear so
actually to prove the KCAL type bound
what Michele and quadratus who indeed is
is proving kind of various bound for
functions which is which has like an
infinity norm bounded and where the
right hand side only depends on the no.1
norm of the partial derivatives so it
doesn't involve any l2 no of course by
doing that you lose a factor of square
root log and and actually and this apply
implies the Gaussian bomb I mean the KL
bound for the Gaussian measure so I mean
though I earlier proof of Ladue uses the
hyper contractive bounds and this proof
from going from the m2 norm to l1 norm
this is a simple one useful fact that if
you have a function which is bounded
then there is no way you can bound the
derivative of the function in enmity
norm but you can if you can smooth it by
applying the semi goof for example here
is the Austrian limit semigroup you can
bound the derivative in the end infinity
norm by by some constant and you pay the
price of 1 over square root P so this is
helpful in bounding the derivative of
the smooth version of the
it'd be norm of the smooth version of
the function by the corresponding l1
norm and that's kind of their their
proof okay so let me move on to the one
application of the KK and theorem and in
the gaussian space so for that I need
the gooses lemma so fortunately for our
definitions we have the corresponding
version of the Russos Lemar now the of
course the now now the majors are normal
theta one and we have a suppose we have
an increasing set then if you take the
derivative of this measure of the set
with respect to theta you have the sum
of the gaussian influence and i mean the
proof is very easy you approximate the
indicator function by a smooth function
you write the left-hand side like this
expectation of this function so an
exerciser iodine or milles okay and
you've been take the derivative and it
becomes the sum of the partial
derivative so so this is easy extremely
easy and as a corollary so if you have a
Gaussian space if you have a function
which is increasing and also transitive
then you have the same threshold
phenomenon but now the threshold window
is 1 over square root login because in
the k KL bound we have square root of
logins and so whenever you have this
transitive condition all the influences
are the same so this derivative is
roughly of the order of square root log
in and actually this threshold window is
tight for this set maximum of X I
greater than equal to its median so note
that this set is a fully symmetric so
it's this rate is invariant under the
full permutation group so so it's a kind
of a natural question to ask which is
kind of which is open question that what
kind of condition you want to impose on
your sake a what kind of symmetry
condition other symmetry condition you
want to improve on you set a such that
you have a sharper
threshold Windom of course like the
corresponding results like you cannot
expect that just like having the full
symmetry of the coroners cannot give you
a sharper threshold because of this
counter example there must be some other
end of criteria okay so how much time do
I have
so next time want to talk about the
noise sensitivity in the Gaussian space
so actually defined everything for me
and in his last talk but so just recall
what do you mean by noise sensitivity in
the discrete Q so this is kind of the
weak noise sensitivity so in general
noise sensitivity measures if you part
up randomly if you add a small
perturbation on the input randomly so
how much the functional value affects by
this by that perturbation now formally
so suppose X is uniform on the discreet
cube and X eta is the eternally copy of
X which is defined by this that you keep
the same coordinate with probability 1
minus theta and take a independent
Bernoulli with probability eat up then
on for any functions defined on the
discreet Q you can define this noise
sensitive with the function of F at the
noise level eta is just the covariance
between the random variables FX and FX
Sica and you say that a sequence of
function is effing critically noise
sensitive if this covariance goes to 0
for any fixed data and actually it has
connections to the lower level for your
mass of this function so for every fixed
D if you look at the total for your mass
between the sets of size 1 and D that
goes to 0 and a non trivial example of
this kind of functions with which is my
sensitive is the event of having a left
to right crossing in the N by n box in
the 2 dimensional critical percolation
where you keep each edge with
probability 1/2 and unit it with
probability 1/2
and in this very influential paper
Benjamin E coli and some proof that this
if you have a sequence of set that is
asymptotically noise sensitive if the
following condition is satisfied so you
take the square of the influences and
sum it up if that goes to 0 then the
sets are f in particular you know it's
sensitive and actually the converse is
also true if the sets are movable and
actually the monotron sets are the sets
of interesting in practical examples so
so this is this Benjamin E coli and
Shawn theorems ties the concept of my
sensitivity to the influences ok and now
how do you define the Gaussian you know
I sense everybody will you do the
obvious things you take a W and a like
square root of 1 minus Rho Square
correlated copy of W which I call it W
Rho up there and you define the same way
Gaussian my sensitivity just the
covariance between the random variables
fw + fw Rho so this is the kind of the
Austrian Olympic perturbation that we
are doing here and we can prove the
similar kind of benjamina college and
some results in the gaussian space so so
we prove that a sequence of sets in the
gaussian space is asymptotically
gaussian by sensitive so you define the
gaussian noise sensitive in the
following way that in the same way as
before by saying that a sequence is
asymptotically gaussian why sensitive if
the corresponding noise sensitivity
function of this of the sets goes to 0
as K tends to infinity infinity so thus
we have the same sufficient condition
now you replace the influences by
geometric influences and again this
converse holds if the same sermon
so actually one can prove a quantity
version of this theorem so you what you
do actually I mean this if you look at
the original BK s theorem
it doesn't says it only says it is a
qualitative statement because it says
that some quantity goes to 0 then the
other quantity goes to 0 but it doesn't
say how these two quantity is the sum of
the squares of the influences and this
noise sensitivity function is related so
so actually tailor and Kilner to the
following quantity reversion of this
because theorem and they prove that this
nice sensitive function is bounded by
some function of the sum of the squares
of the influences to the power some
constant times theta so this is true for
all eater
the constants are universal yeah so yeah
so the functions are bounded between 0
and 1 this is a functional version and
also is a quadratic function of the
biggest theorem and I mean you can
easily turn this theorem into a kind of
a Gaussian version and where instead of
the influences you now have the lor norm
square so which are done for the sense
they're the Gaussian influences okay so
you have the same things I mean you get
a Rho square because of the fact that I
mean because of the parametrization
so if I if I take square root of Rho
there you will get a row so the
correlation between W and W Rho as Rho
is close to 1 I think no so Rho is
closed went okay right right I mean it's
not a very good primary radiation so so
the correlation between my W end of the
row is is and in the previous slide I
used the correlation of X and each a
noisy copy of X as 1 minus theta so eta
is 1 minus 1 minus Rho square okay so as
the row when the row is small this ETA
is roughly like Rho square so that
that's why you get the row squares so
there is nothing special about that
and okay so I just wanted to include the
slides so how do you put that to
emphasize how simple it is once you have
the theorem in the discrete space so you
just use the central limit theorem so
you approximate this function f which is
a function of the Gaussian random
variable by the this normalized
independent Bernoulli random variable
okay and you just apply the central
limit theorem then kind of the noise
sensitivity function will converge to
the corresponding Gaussian my sensitive
function and the sum of squares of these
influences they will converge to the sum
of the Gaussian influences square sorry
sum of the squares of the ocean
influences and the proof is actually
very trivial I mean you just write what
the discrete influence is and you apply
the mean value theorem and you will get
a 1 over square root n factor and which
cancels with this square root M and so
on so forth it's very easy so so this is
this is just to emphasize I mean how you
can use some of the well-known results
in the discrete phase and transferred it
to the Gaussian space and get some
interesting results yeah in the Gaussian
case it's easier oh I mean no I I mean
once you have dug these children in the
discrete space you have the fuel in the
ocean is there some hope to give an
easier the REC to finge of them so
that's my next slide so actually yes I
so the natural question is is there a
direction to go poo veneers actually
subsequently and bori which is a student
of mission they do
he gave a direct proof using the
standards and tools and their proof is
kind of applicable not only in the
Gaussian setting but also in the
discrete setting but also have the semi
group prove you it can
you generalize too many years of context
and and there is one more generalization
what we did so for for us the functions
are bounded function so the function
takes the value between 0 & 1 & 4 for
him he takes the general functions in l2
and on the right hand side it involves a
factor of the entry norm of this
function but the exponent is of the same
order okay
yes yes actually I mean the noise
sensitivity in general I mean it was
introduced to for the functions with
boolean valued functions and in that
case also you consider the function
sense measure like half or something
like non degenerate functions yeah so I
mean if the functions of the various
goes to 0 that is very uninteresting
unless you change unless education
definition kind of I mean the
normalization is kind of this like
nickim or something it goes away okay so
there I want to then it's very
interesting if you journey and once you
change the finishing it can be very
interesting so yeah so yeah we have to
find like these good examples to where
we can apply like this kind of nice and
simple definition yeah but there is
something to be done there okay so so
the next result is the Paladins result
actually Nathan talked about this so if
you have to increasing success in the
discrete hypercube the peregrines proved
a beautiful theorem which gives a lower
bound between the correlation between
the sets a and B in terms of the sum of
the products of the influences okay and
this function is x over log of y over X
so this is a very influential paper by
Allah grant and actually we can we can
just use telegrams result to get a
Gaussian analogue and now just so that
we have the increasing substrates in RN
now this this influences are replaced by
ocean universes and we had the exact
same result so we don't have to do any
work
so basically idris prove if you have
seen it it involves kind of integrate
but beautiful induction argument and so
so that all the work is done here in the
discrete space and we are just kind of
taking the central limit theorem and
which goes in our favor is that the
influences appears as the quadratic
function so so you have the sum of the
squares of the influences converges to
the sum of the squares of the geometric
influences so we can apply that and we
get the result of course they term it's
the natural question that is there a
direct semigroup roof of the of this
result so because of course it's not
just mathematical curiosity curiosity
but if you have a direct semigroup proof
you can like generalize to various other
Markov semigroup so it will be
interesting to see if there is a kind of
a direct semi-good proof of this result
okay so I'll stop here
so no sensitivity when you go into two
points then independence and asymptotic
on correlation that are equivalent in
your case you're mapping into the reals
aha so being uncorrelated and being
independent but not the same okay you
chose but the definition you chose was
that they're uncorrelated yes I guess
you could have chosen this is it would
be the stronger things true you could
also ask first at all since DVD would be
stronger exam if you want to independent
right yeah so when you get the strong so
I guess the stronger thing if you want
to asymptotic independence you sort of
say if I compose F we've got another guy
going in two points I get asymptotic
uncorrelated yes we do with the therapy
true with the analog of the bks theorem
then V true that some of the scores
won't do it then you can compose so they
really become asymptotically independent
not just uncorrelated yeah so I haven't
thought about that so yeah this is
something something quick journey good
question
so we actually consider the functions
like like proving the functional Russian
means sometimes is easier that's the
thing so we wanted to restrict to the
like boolean value function but then we
realized if you go to the functional
version which functions taking values in
there in the real line the proofs
becomes much easier and I said we'll do
it and so on and so forth so we I mean
you stick to that but I mean for like we
have in mind that we will apply it to
the only the boolean value function but
your question is